two years ago blessing a sock way
arrived in Russia coming she thought to
work in a supermarket to earn money to
support her family in Nigeria two years
later she's going home in a wheelchair
and mom she arrived and her Nigerian
traffickers told her she had to work to
pay back the money they'd spent on
bringing her to Russia her debt was
$40,000 she says she had to repay it by
having sex some pens down 1.5 sometimes
5 me for me 6 they tried to make you do
some stuff that you don't so bond win
disagreeing then threaten to cube the
video then won the money they paid back
so our tanks we because of his often and
after the sleeping with many of them so
we disagreeing Givaudan Baldy moon so
they have to beat the pit stop personal
[ __ ] me opening a wobbling show me out
from the back on the balcony was on the
4th floor of a building when she hit the
ground blessing broke her hip she was in
intensive care for two days and says her
treatment was stopped because she
couldn't afford to pay across Moscow in
a different flat that's serving as a
shelter another group of girls have
similar stories each year outreach
workers say around two to three thousand
Nigerian girls are trafficked into
Russia for sex many of them they say are
brought here on documents issued by
institutions which should be keeping
them safe I've got three passports here
where all the girls are on student visas
and the allegation that outreach workers
are making is that there is an
international trafficking network which
is bringing the girls here it has links
to the Russian and Nigerian authorities
and when they get here they are being
sold into sex
Kenny Qian de is one of the few people
in Moscow working to support women who
have escaped the sex trade this is
international modern-day slavery because
nobody can get this imitation target
without
FMS which is the Russian immigration
that gives this of this ancient idiom to
come here and the school is aware they
are not coming here to study because
they are all dressed of them that come
floating every year they never end up in
school yep develop and assess sex
slavery the university which issued
blessings documents told me she never
turned up to study it also said it had
no idea whether or not she was actually
in the country because she didn't tell
them but it strongly denied any
suggestion of corruption or being
involved in a trafficking ring the
Russian Federal Migration Service told
us it regularly checks for visa
violations but despite several requests
it has not explained how blessing a sock
way and girls like her are able to
arrive in the country on student visas
and apparently disappear from sights
into the sex trade
although blessing has now escaped to
that trade she cannot leave it behind
completely your parents are they happy
you're coming home mmm why aren't they
happy she's happy I'm coming on board
she's pissed on that I came here with my
two legs and I was aiding and coming
back on which I'm coming to Russia has
changed blessing forever it's not yet
clear if she'll walk properly again she
has a message to other girls from
Nigeria approached like her with offers
of work abroad
stay back home the pay is small she says
but it's better than coming here to lose
your life